Here are the classes that I found. Person, we know about that one. String and
Array List, I'm not worried about those, many classes use them. System right
here, where we have system.out. And Print Stream, that's a hard one actually,
because the print stream class is never mentioned explicitly. One would just
have to know that system.out is an object off the print stream class. Now, I am
a bit bothered about that dependency, because it means that the car class can
only work in an environment where I actually have a console, that would mean
any computer. And these days, does your cell phone have a console, does a
toaster oven? I don't really like to build on a dependency on system.out and
print stream if I can avoid it.